what we're gonna answer in this video is
what is a limit and when is there no
limit okay and we're also going to talk
about how to find limits so first things
first what is the limit well what a
limit is is say you're getting closer
closer closer and closer like infinitely
close to a particular point on a graph
what is that y-value what is that output
okay sometimes when you get right on
that point it doesn't even exist so what
you're doing is you're approaching it
you're getting infinitely close you
don't have to actually arrive at that
point but you're just almost there what
is it that you're approaching what is
that value okay and does it exist
so if I have to do just a simple little
graph here for you if you can see this
say your graph was like say it was like
this okay
and say this value here is one so as I'm
approaching one from the left side okay
so from the left I'm following the graph
just like you're following a road you're
going along the road from the left here
you're getting closer and closer to the
x value of one you're also approaching
from the right side okay as you're
getting closer and closer to one and
you're saying hmm what is the output or
the Y value when x equals one okay so on
this graph it looks like it's also going
to be one the Y value that's the output
that's going to be one so you're
approaching it you don't necessarily
have to get there and you want to know
what's the Y value at that point so when
is there no limit let's talk about that
so no limit is when there's an unbounded
situation okay what's an unbounded
situation I'm about a situation would
look like this say for example you have
an asymptote okay like this there's an
asymptote at x equals two and let's say
from the left the graph is going up
towards positive infinity
and the graph from the right let's say
it's going down towards negative
infinity and you want to know what's the
limit as X approaches two well you can
see as you get closer and closer to the
x value of two the Y values are going
right up to positive infinity okay and
then from the right side as you approach
x equals two the Y values okay are going
towards negative infinity
you're not approaching the same value
okay you're going actually in opposite
directions one deposit if any one to
negative infinity even if this graph
here was also going towards positive
infinity
you're not approaching a fixed value
like a constant it's just going up and
up and up forever you can never you know
it just goes to infinity that's
considered unbounded as well now the
next part when there's not a limit is
when the left-sided limit does not equal
the right-sided limit so that could be a
scenario where like I'll see if I can
draw you another diagram here it's like
say for example one graph is going like
this and another graph is maybe going
like this and say you're trying to
approach this value right here so as you
get closer to this x-value from the left
and you approach that x-value from the
right it's like you know it's like
you're trying to meet your friend at a
particular location it's like your
friend goes somewhere else and it's like
okay we met at the same time but we were
in two different spots right so that is
also considered no limit or does not
exist okay for the limit and then
oscillating is where you're approaching
that particular x value but no matter
how much you zoom in say you're on your
graphing calculator you zooming in the
graph keeps going like this it keeps
oscillating keeps bouncing back and
forth between maybe two different values
no matter how much you zoom in it's
constantly going back and forth okay you
can't really nail it down to one output
that's oscillating that's also no limit
so three different cases and then now
how to find limits well there's a lot of
different techniques okay one technique
is you can use direct substitution if
you have an equation you can try and put
that x value right into the equation
simplify and see if you get an output
now sometimes what happens when you do
direct substitution is you get 0/0
okay now up to this point you probably
haven't seen this but this is considered
an indeterminate form means we can't
really determine in what it is it's not
0 it's not one it's not undefined we
have to analyze it further and that's
how we get into some of these other
techniques so you could of course graph
it like some of these graphs we've been
doing here on your graphing calculator
by hand and then approach that value and
see what the output is the Y value or
you can make a table okay so what you
can do you can see like this table here
I made
use this and one of the other examples
is you're gonna zero in on that
particular x value from below meaning
like slightly less than that value and
from above slightly greater than that
value and you're gonna see if the Y
values that or the outputs are
approaching the same quantity if they
are then that's your limit if they're
not approaching two different values
then there's no limit we can also use a
dividing out technique which is where
you're gonna factor okay
see if you do some cancellation first
and then do direct substitution and then
sometimes you're gonna have some
radicals and what you can do is a
rationalizing technique and I'll show
you these in the next few examples we're
going to do so you're ready for the
examples let's let's get into those so
let's look at some graphs first of all
okay see if you can answer these
questions as we go along when you look
at this one the limit as X approaches
one of the function this is our function
graphed here what's the limit as X
approaches one can you can you see what
it is okay so as we're approaching one
right here that's going to be right
there so as we approach one from the
left and we approach it from the right
side you can see it looks like it's
gonna be right at to the Y values -
sometimes when students are first
learning about limits they're like
what's going on right this is crazy
it's hard to figure out what's actually
happening but what you're doing is
you're trying to approach the x value of
one so you pretend like you're driving
along a road you're on the graph you're
going towards one you have to follow the
road you can't just go right towards one
you follow the road you're getting
closer and closer to one and you look at
what that y value is you do the same
thing for the right side and you look at
the what the Y value is if they are
approaching the same y value that's your
limit so this one's going to be two okay
so you're with me so far okay so hang in
there we'll do some more you'll see how
it works so the limit as X approaches
two now so now we're trying to approach
- well you can see something's
interesting is happening here we have an
asymptote as we approach from the left
we're going up to positive infinity
right right off the whiteboard if we
approach here from the right side we're
going down towards negative infinity
we're not approaching the same point
like this we're going like this so this
one is Diani does not exist okay no
limit okay so you could say doesn't
exist or no limit all right let's go to
this one over here now see if you can
get this one on your own
the line'
as X approaches 1 of f of X okay so as
we approach x equals 1 what's the Y
value see when you see f of X that's the
Y value that's the output this is
telling you we want to approach the x
value of 1 okay so we're cruising along
from the left side in the right side and
you say wait a second there's a hole
there so there isn't a value right well
not quite as remember'd limits we don't
have to actually get there we have to
get infinitely close we're getting
closer closer closer closer what value
are we getting closer to well as you
approach from the left and the right
you're getting closer closer closer that
Y value is approaching 3 okay even
though this point doesn't exist the
limit means as you get infinitely close
you don't actually get to that point
you're just approaching it ok so this
one's going to be 3 all right let's go
over to this one here you probably can
guess what this one is the limit as X
approaches 0 of the function right as
you get closer and closer to 0 what's
happening here can you see it's
oscillating ok and I just try to do my
best to illustrate this but if you were
to zoom in on this you would still see
this you know ricocheting effect back
and forth between negative 2 & 2 and so
this just is also it does not exist and
you could explain further you could say
oscillating that's the reason it doesn't
exist okay this one over here what's the
limit as X approaches negative 3 of the
function okay so this is our function
what do you think the limit is doesn't
exist right as we approach from the left
as we approach from the right they're
approaching two different Y values
they're not approaching the same point
like that this one is no limit and
that's because the left side and the
right side don't match now I want to
show you something a little bit
different on this problem if you add a
little minus sign okay so when you see
this in your textbooks it's really small
sometimes it's even easy to miss you say
this - doesn't have anything to do with
negative numbers it says as you approach
negative 3 this minus means from the
left so as you approach negative 3 from
the left what's the limit well for this
one the limit would be negative 2 we're
approaching this point the Y value are
getting closer and closer to negative 2
if I changes to
a plus sign like that as you're
approaching from the right from the
positive side what's the limit of the
function as you approach negative three
that's going to be positive two okay so
you're with me so far
but if this is not there if I just
eliminate that altogether then there's
no limit because they're actually
approaching two different Y values so
you want to make sure the left side and
the right side match unless they're
specifically telling us you know right
side left side plus means from the right
minus means from the left okay with me
so far
okay now we're going to get into some of
the algebra techniques so seem to give
us this equation right here the limit as
X approaches 4 of this function 4x plus
7 well the first thing you want to do
when you do these limits okay is always
just to check direct substitution if you
put 4 right in for X what does that give
you well it gives you 16 plus 7 which is
23 and that's our limit
so there's no no no issues there no
problem let's go over to this one over
here now so this one let's go ahead and
do that direct substitution technique if
we put five in we get zero if we put 5
in here we get 5 squared is 25 minus 25
is 0 we're getting zero over zero
that's our indeterminate form we can't
tell what the limit is so we don't give
up yeah we go to some of our other
techniques we could graph it like we did
up here ok that's one option we can make
a table like I was showing you here
we're trying to zero in on 5 so I picked
some points that are a little bit less
than 5 and a little bit greater than 5
and I got progressively closer closer
closer you can do this on your graphing
calculator or by hand and you want to
see if you're approaching the same you
know value now if I put 5 in you know
your calculators going to say error okay
because you can't you know it's
indeterminate you can't divide by 0 but
you want to see if this one and this one
the ones where you're really close to 5
a little bit less and a little bit
greater if they're approaching that same
number that would be your limit but in
this technique let's use the factoring
technique so we're going to factor this
this is X minus 5 over X plus 5 X minus
5 it's a difference of two squares
okay the X minus 5s are going to cancel
so we have 1 over X plus 5 now let's do
the direct substitution we're going to
put 5 in here that's 10 so
limit is 1/10 or 0.1 and you would see
that these two values would be really
close to 0.1 okay so with me so far
let's do a few more examples let's look
at this one here now this one again we
were finding the limit as X approaches 3
right so we can put 3 in here but notice
what's going to happen we're going to be
dividing by 0 and we're gonna be getting
0 in the numerator again it's
indeterminate like this ok so we want to
use another technique and and this one
what we're going to do is we're gonna
use the rationalizing technique so when
you see this radical think about
rationalizing and what we're gonna do is
we're going to multiply by the conjugate
so you probably remember from you know
other parts of this year or last year or
how you multiply by the conjugate it's
the square root of x plus 6 not minus 3
but the opposite plus 3 and this was
plus I would make this minus the
opposite and you're gonna do the same
thing to the denominator okay because
anything divided by itself is 1 so it's
not going to change the overall value of
this rational expression this fraction
it's just gonna change the way that it
looks okay it's gonna make it easier for
us to find the limit so we're going to
do the foiling method okay or you can
distribute like this and if we do that
square root of x plus 6 times square
root of x plus 6 just gives you X plus 6
okay whenever you multiply square root
times itself you just get what's
underneath the inside and the outside
those are gonna cancel each other out
and negative 3 times positive 3 is
negative 9
now the denominator I'm just gonna leave
in factored form so this is X minus 3
times the square root of x plus 6 plus 3
okay 6 minus 9 is negative 3 so we have
X minus 3 and you can see that the X
minus 3 and the X minus 3 and the
numerator and denominators are going to
cancel so we're really just left with 1
divided by this here okay now let's go
ahead and put 3 and now so if we put 3
and we get 3 plus 6 is 9 the square root
of 9 is 3 plus 3 is 6 so the limit is
going to be 1/6 okay so just to recap
really quick we multiply by the
conjugate okay so we change a sign to
the opposite we wanted to do the same
thing in the numerator and denominator
so that we can rationalize meaning
you know get rid of the radical in the
numerator here and then at that point we
said well let's go ahead and do our
direct substitution technique let's put
three in we weren't getting the
indeterminate form that we were getting
originally the zero over zero we've got
one sixth and that's our limit so we
just used a rewriting technique
specifically rationalizing with what
they call this technique but you can see
we did the factoring technique okay what
often times called the dividing out
technique so we've got a lot of
different techniques for finding limits
everything from graphing to direct
substitution to making tables and so on
so I hope you're enjoying the videos
that I'm producing here for you go ahead
and subscribe to the channel I look
forward to seeing you in future videos
and check out some of my past videos but
I'll see you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon